it is lucky number seven for the golden
tiki the las vegas staple is celebrating
their seventh anniversary with seven
days of fun plus a world record attempt
here to tell us more is their beverage
director the fabulous adam rains welcome
back thank you it's great to be back so
good to have you congratulations on
seven years that is
not surprising because the golden tiki
is probably one of the best places to
celebrate anything here in town tell us
what you guys have going on
oh it's gonna be an exciting week we
have uh every night so we have seven
nights of festivities celebrating all
the seven years like you mentioned so
tonight we are doing our fez night so
we're debuting our new fez oh
how do i get myself one of those those
are cool i think you should come in
tonight okay i'll do that sip on a tasty
libation and listen to exotica and
they'll be right there for you okay well
speaking of tasty libations you guys are
attempting to break a world record
now what is this tell us more so we are
we are so that'll be the culmination of
all seven days and by the way every day
we have live music and djs and all types
of events but the culmination is on
world mai tai day next tuesday and we'll
we're going to be attempting the world's
largest mai tai oh can you show me how
to make one here absolutely okay let's
do it i mean this won't be the world's
largest but this will be the world's
best because it's made by you let's make
it happen all right
my ties i love my ties what do you got
here so this one is a version of the
1944 trader vic style my title okay
which is wonderfully balanced um it's uh
tart has a little bit tart sweet strong
a little bit of everything okay looking
for so what was this that is fresh lime
juice
very very ominous looking with those
potions on it skull island potions
that's what we make there i love it and
then we'll do orjat which is an almond
flour orange
orange flower syrup okay this one's made
by dressed to drink here locally for us
i love it i have an orange liqueur
original version has an orange curacao
this is an italian orange liqueur these
are pretty potent it looks like things
there's going to be some things
happening here so um the original
version you cannot really make again
because they don't make the original rum
which was like a 17-year-old aged
jamaican rum okay so to put the jamaican
pot still in there we have a little bit
of smith and cross but we just put a
couple bar spoons just a tiny little bit
just a little bit okay because this is
very potent both in flavor and in
in alcohol content i'm gonna move this
so people can see what you've got going
on here wonderful and then next we have
an aged puerto rican rum
nice lots of room and finally an age
venezuelan rum
which is column and pot still it brings
a lot of flavor to the party the smell
just i i'm feeling like just beach vibes
right now it smells so good absolutely
so let's shake it up what we're going to
do is just put a little bit of ice in
there and shake her up
i love the shake that's my favorite part
you do that with such grace is there
like a shaking school you go to for that
you know
sort of it's every night at the golden
tiki we're just shaking and shaking and
shaking i love it okay um
but there's actually complete books
written about shaking is there really oh
wow yeah okay let's see all right so
we're just going to pour it
pour it directly in there and then i'm
going to douse it with as much
pellet ice as can fit you guys so the
ice is a golden tiki this is i'm serious
the pellet ice makes all the difference
absolutely see what you want to do is
you want to get that ice crown so it
insulates the cocktail okay makes a
colder cocktail is a better cocktail i
believe i think we all can agree right
yes for sure and then you just what did
you do with the mint ooh the mint so we
bless bless the cocktail but you're
really just getting the oils all over
there oh okay you know you've seen some
people do the slap yeah which is great
but i then it's mint oils on your hand i
smell it though yes this whole area
absolutely all right we've got about 20
seconds all right so then we have our
lime
and we'll do a little cherry just for
the the color and then we have one of
our golden tiki custom glass straws okay
so people want to be a part of this big
anniversary celebration where's the
golden tiki and when does it starts
tonight right starts tonight ends next
tuesday golden tikis in chinatown on
spring mountain and we have uh you can
come for our new my seventh anniversary
my thai glass as well oh adam that is
fabulous i'm there and i'm gonna can i
wear one of the fuzzes absolutely is
this is this allowed this is allowed
okay we're ready ready to celebrate
that's right do you want to tell
everyone what's coming up next what